lost it another turnover picked up by
Hardy I was outstanding defense egged
Olive Oh with the steal nice deflection
otherwise capella would have a dumb play
Thompson for fridge sloppy with the ball
early each with four turnovers in less
than seven minutes
Thompson long three-pointer his rivers
hits inside layup points for harden they
while the Rockets as Luna T drives down
a lane how about that looting off the
dribble to the basket no help
defensively that mislead for sustained
period of time - that was that was a
tough possession Tucker
three Lodi gets away from the
double-team cook pull up shot won't go
Looney on the follow I'm Mike D'Antoni
I'm saying how bad do you guys want to
win because we understood coming in that
this was a problem
it's not just plain cappella
responsibily small gets into the paint
falling away cat it looked like it was
over fruit falls as I still have
something in my tank to fake pass the
ability to get into the paint and a top
Deus Caritas repco drip go back the
Livingstone throws it down now the
Warriors of tie the game in a step up
Martin shot blocked again now at
Thompson with another double team and a
hardened drive rain layup and foul
throws it down and the lead is eight
that was given Steve Kerr some good
limits gets inside nice feed bank shot
is good from draymond Green I mean curry
has been the one guy we all thought
would absolutely deliver but so far not
at all without the basketball on that
possession was a clinic and that defense
was awful 18 points here are the opening
half of Game six cook couldn't handle a
pass
Green fakes the past buyers afraid
Rockets after trailing by eight regain
the lead play Thompson's step back
that's good
klay Thompson are lighting it up Mike
D'Antoni told us before the game that
without Kevin Durant they were going to
make sure that they could back to
Curry's penetration Chris Paul gets it
back again now it likes to mismatch with
Bogut on him
puts the three up over ball got an exit
dominate anticipation by Harden against
that slip he was second in the NBA
during the regular season
step back prey
[Applause]
get down with the steel curry Thompson
3-pointer got it
Houston curry it's not that time - reco
goes flying into the rebound
stolen by Tucker there's Chris Paul to
the basket off the last name I'm in a
third quarter
[Applause]
ball gets inside my speed Capello at the
finish five seconds all the drive throws
it up throws it down and all first ball
does is get play Thompson off move and
gets a matchup he likes falling away
bottle the way they won Game five in
Oakland and they pull out Game six curry
gets to the basket nobody there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry long distance that's a three-step
curry his second three-pointer hardened
bad ass [ __ ] dolla knocked it away ball
got hit in the eye Livingston drives
left-handed backs at home it's a tie
game that's shooting then that's the
right basketball play
we haven't at any points in three
minutes and that drought ends right
there dream on green setting up come on
Looney Looney with 14 points like
anxious moments for the Rockets fans so
many on their feet right now
curry launches a three-pointer Hudson
and Steph Curry from downtown and the
lead is 5 for Golden State
[Applause]
curry on the drive gets past lamb
bank shot is good Steph Curry coming
alive for the second straight game in
the fourth quarter
[Music]
curry with Tucker Wright Willam curry
launches a three from downtown
we approach a minute remaining james
harden on the drive trying to draw some
contact facts at home
courage surrounded fives dream on dream
breeds of the basket kicks it out again
our Thompson for three plates turned
into a six-point deficit
brothers they pockets here in the
forecourt